everyone knows that brie Larson's
Captain Marvel is as strong a superhero
as the Marvel Cinematic Universe has
ever seen
Marvel head honcho Kevin Feige has even
repeatedly stated that she's the most
powerful hero in the entire film
franchise so far with that in mind it's
not hugely surprising that Carole was
able to fly in and rescue Iron Man and
nebula at the beginning of Avengers
endgame without even breaking a sweat
and yet Captain Marvel's photon blasting
fists and otherworldly strength aren't
quite enough to distract from one big
question how did she actually find them
well Avengers endgame co-director Joe
Russo has finally revealed the answer in
the commentary track included on the
digital release of Avengers endgame
Russo explained that Carol Danvers
didn't just leave whatever planet she
was on and automatically know where in
space
Tony and nebula were stranded after
receiving an emergency page from Nick
Fury at the end of Avengers infinity war
Carole went to earth first and met with
the Avengers who had survived Thanos is
snap of course many fans will actually
remember this happening since it was
depicted on screen during the
post-credits scene for Captain Marvel
where's fury thanks to Joe Russo however
the final gap in the story has been
filled he explained the missing
narrative of course is that she came to
earth met the Avengers was brought up to
speed on what was happening and there's
some sort of homing beacon on that ship
that she tracks and brings the two of
them back to earth for any endgame
viewers who hadn't stuck around after
Captain Marvel's credits Carole's rescue
of Iron Man and nebula may have been a
little confusing given a lack of content
behind the scene and the missing
narrative Russo mentioned nevertheless
it did an excellent job of tying up the
loose ends left dangling following the
Avengers infinity war post-credit scene
in which fury pages Carol seconds before
he crumbles into dust after Thanos his
initial snap it was also a great way to
bring Captain Marvel into the present
day after her 90 set solo movie and
demonstrate her enormous power to both
the audience and the Avengers
but this wasn't how Captain Marvel was
intended to be introduced Russo also
explained that he co-director Anthony
Russo and screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely originally
wrote the rescue scene without the
reveal that Carroll was responsible for
it the team initially wanted to hide the
fact that Captain Marvel was the hero
who rocked up to the benatar and blew it
back to earth instead it would only be
implied that she was saving Iron Man and
nebula at least at first
McFeely revealed the idea would be that
there'd be orange light on Tony's face
he'd see something the audience wouldn't
see it this is actually pretty close to
what did happen in Avengers endgame but
the earlier cut in the movie wouldn't
have led on that it was Captain Marvel
outside the Bennet are saving the reveal
for when she actually brings the ship
down to earth ultimately the crew
decided that this wouldn't work as a
successful reveal and instead opted to
show off Captain Marvel in all her glory
now that this endgame mystery has
finally been solved Marvel fans can
focus their attention on speculating
when Captain Marvel will make her return
to the MCU for sequel film wasn't
announced as a phase 4 project during
Marvel San Diego comic-con panel but
fans aren't convinced that she'll be
sitting on the sidelines until after
2021 who knows perhaps in the coming
years Carole will swoop in to save her
fellow superheroes once more check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]